[Musique]
alors stéphanie je te présente frères
d'exil de khoshkak un roman jeunesse
pour les 12 ans à peu près sur l'exil et
l'exode de réfugiés donc l'histoire se
passe en polynésie on sait pas trop où
sur une île en fait qui prend qui prend
l'eau donc la greffe le réchauffement
climatique fait qu'en fait il ya une
montée des eaux et qu'ils vont perdre
toute leur terre donc ils se doivent
d'évacuer cette île là donc il ya des
paquebots qui sont mis à leur
disposition fin il ya tout un ton
sanitaire qu'avec est mis à disposition
farenc a mis en place pour l'évacuation
de l'île donc en fait on voit le récit
va de l'exode de sept îles la traversée
via ce paquebot et l'arrivée sur une
terme totalement inconnu en fait les
jeunes vas tu as 10 12 ans oui c'est ça
tout ce qu'on peut entendre actuellement
sur les réfugiés et qu'est ce qu'un
réfugié quoi il y en a voilà et de
comprendre en fait quelle est leur
position dans notre vie à nous et quel
est l'intérêt et la place cruciale
qu'ils ont par rapport à nos sociétaires
nous qui finalement se ferme à beaucoup
de choses mais là ce sont des réfugiés
suite à un des événements plutôt
écologique totalement rester sur les
relations bâties donc pas de guerre mais
je pense que de toute façon des réfugiés
climatiques il va y en avoir de plus en
plus ça il faut pas se leurrer mais
alors l'intérêt aussi de deux frères
d'exil en fait c'est que c'est pas un
grand manque qu'on al'habitude de liens
en fait il est très découpées donc on
voit en fait il ya des passages où il ya
des récits il ya des passages où il ya
des lettres avec un grand-père qui
dialoguent et qui est connecté avec sa
petite fille et il ya aussi beaucoup de
dessins et on voit aussi beaucoup de
chansons polynésienne donc vraiment ça
c'est un roman qui est très élevé
finalement mais en fait avec un vrai fil
conducteur entre alès et un vrai message
et on voit en fait tout ce lien qui lie
la famille que ce que sai du grand père
la petite fille et ce il trouve aussi un
petit enfant qui vont devoir adopter
donc la famille s'agrandit et
et toute cette villa familiale qui est
totalement perdue qui va quand même
réussir à se retrouver au milieu de la
france dans un petit village et se
reconstruire autour de la famille et à
s'insérer dans notre société comment
arriver effectivement à se réinsérer à
se refaire en face à retrouver les
greens et à revivre par ailleurs
plein d'optimisme est vraiment un très
très beau très très beau récit qu'on est
vraiment très touchant c'est
ses liaisons épistolaire entre le grand
père la petite fille et c'est vraiment
magnifique warren avec voilà hockey bref
d'exil en exil très belle définition de
réfugiés très bien
laurent je te présente légende en
enveloppes qui vient de paraître en
poche c'est un petit livre qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur que j'ai trouvé
très original et très audacieux
l'auteur est grand reporter en fait au
nouvel obs et un jour en achetant
différents objets d'une même famille
dont un sur sur ebay elle a trouvé une
enveloppe dans laquelle il y avait une
centaine de photos faisait 70 ce genre
tu sais les polars
elle a beaucoup intrigué et elle en a
fait un roman cirque est là elle a comme
ça a pris quelques photos et elle s'est
imaginé une histoire un roman b les
connaissait avant tout non non c'est des
gens qui avait vidé une maison voilà ce
qu'ils avaient et voilà tout simplement
et puis comme elle et elle est
journaliste
elle a été curieuse elle s'est dit mais
finalement ces gens il existe bien ils
sont bien réels donc elle a mené une
enquête pour savoir quel était enfin qui
étaient ces gens quelle est leur
histoire et les offres low cost et elle
les a retrouvés donc le livre se
présente en trois parties donc la
première partie où donc tu as le roman
qu elle l a inventé les photos qu'elle
est là qu'elle a sélectionnés puis
ensuite l'enquète qu'elle a mené le
guardian énormément une redondance entre
les deux cercles musicaux prénom est là
imaginez enfin voilà elle est partie
surtout du du portrait de cette jeune
fille est
nous à partir de saleté cherchait un
prénom elle a imaginé beaucoup de choses
et en fait quand l afem enquête il ya
beaucoup de choses qui se sont régalés
oui mais il désire qui se sont révélées
être tout à fait ce que elle elle avait
inventé ok voilà son récit finalement a
frôlé la vérité totalement voilà alors
c'est vrai que le fait qu'elle soit
journaliste est là elle a en fait les
outils entre guillemets pour pour se
poser les bonnes questions et pour
chercher et puis pour trouver aussi mais
il ya une redondance entre les deux
entre le roman et les enquêtes qui
donnent finalement à l'ouvragé un objet
l'entraîneur doc et on a intérêt du
roman mais alors l'anc est finalement et
comment c'est vrai dire que à partir
d'une photo elle a essayé déterminée ou
à vient habiter cette cette famille est
ensuite une fois qu'elle avait trouvé le
village elle est allée sur place et puis
elle a elle a interrogé en train dé
photos là pour essayer de voir si ces
gens étaient toujours en vie qui êtes à
l'aise qu'elle vous a rencontré oui et
en fait c'est ça qui est génial c'est
que c'est la rencontre avec un des
personnages avec d'autres sur le premier
c'est comme si elle est là un rendez
vous amoureux est là est là elle est
impatiente de voir et pas mal c'est
imaginer beaucoup de choses sur 60
personnes voilà comment va être cette
première rencontre et c'est absolument
passionnant d'abord c'est très émouvant
et puis le livre se concluent également
avec la mise en musique et en chansons
de cette histoire donc et fait donc part
par alex beaupain voilà qui est en fait
le le c'est lui qui fait également les
musiques des films de christophe honoré
d'accord et l'on peut trouver dans le
gourma le cdh est décédé dans le grand
format et là dans la version poche en
fait dans le livre il y a en fait un
code à télécharger pour pouvoir
télécharger la musique mais des légendes
en enveloppes donc d'isabelle monin et
c'est une vraie pépite
alors aujourd'hui j'ai présenté nouveau
livre chez albin michel c'est un beau
livre sur les écrivains américains donc
il s'intitule l'amérique des écrivains
en liberté d'accord c'est un livre dans
lequel tu vas retrouver en très peu de
pages une description de l'univers des
grands écrivains américains qui me
connaît nous américains contemporains
donc comme jim harrison qui vient de
décéder
pollock laura kasischke enfin tous les
grands noms de la littérature américaine
on découvre d'où ils viennent ce qui les
inspire comment ils vivent au quotidien
graphique ouais une bio mais en fait les
auteurs vont rencontrer chaque écrivain
et ils les ont fait parler sur leur
influence leur univers et quelle est
leur vision de l'amérique d'aujourd'hui
d'accord alors c'est que enfin c'est pas
que des causes américain des grands
espaces comme on entend beaucoup parler
en ce moment il va y avoir du pôle
austère donc un milieu très urbain et
puis les grands espaces de jim harrison
on découvre tout un peu tous les états
des états unis et leur vie et ça ne
parle qu'aux amérique enfin s'élance
d'américains qui ont interrogé des
amériques et non ses deux deux
journalistes français d'accord qui sont
allés à la rencontre des grands auteurs
américains et
découvre que certains vivent plutôt bien
des grands domaines et puis on a
d'autres qui ont une vie assez difficile
et qui sont encore un petit peu en
difficulté financière ont sombré ou qui
s'en sont sortis dans l'alcool la drogue
enfin d'accord c'est quoi il ya des
portraits il ya des photos tout à fait
que tu vas avoir des paysages qui
illustre l'état d'outils d'où ils
viennent des photos assez atypique est
toujours une photo pleine page de
l'auteur du portrait
très intéressant oui c'est vraiment très
intéressant est ce que le rectorat tout
à fait et on découvre des auteurs dont
on n'a jamais entendu parler ou très peu
donc ça donne envie de découvrir en plus
des romans qui sont pas su adam michel
donc je trouve que de la part de
l'éditeur c'est plutôt c'est plutôt vers
intelligent ok donc l'amérique des
écrivains en liberté tout à fait
laurent je te présente un gros coup de
coeur on va dire
noam la nuit de kent haruf qui est un
livre très doux d'une simplicité
incroyable
débordante amour et d'une grande
tendresse avec ça d'accord voilà
l'histoire d'un homme et d'une femme qui
ont 70 ans passés veuve tous les deux et
qui vont tenter malgré les conventions
sociales de vivre une histoire tous les
deux on est au fin fond d'une petite
bourgade aux états unis ont finalement
les le qu'en-dira-t-on et les
conventions sociales perdurent et
finalement on s'aperçoit que même à 70
ans passés et ben elles peuvent encore
nous compliquer la vie à un point
inimaginable
c'est très très beau c'est très doux est
simple je disais parce que finalement ça
va pas plus loin que un homme et une
femme l'histoire qu'ils vont vivre le
territoire comptant pas tout à fait on
est on est à aujourd'hui mais voilà on a
aujourd'hui au fin fond des états unis
ah oui non totalement aujourd'hui et
c'est ça aussi qui est difficile à se
dire c'est de faire croire c'est de se
dire voilà finalement les conventions
sociales
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui elle perdure et
elles peuvent alors nous bouffer la vie
comme pas possible quoi d'accord donc il
ya encore de l'actualité sur ces
barrières qui existent totalement
gouaoui totalement oui oui parce qu'ils
vont ils vont malheureusement pas
réussir à vivre je raconte pas la femme
plus mais pleinement une histoire qui au
départ est juste une histoire d'amitié
un besoin de tendresse parce qu'en fait
elle va lui faire une proposition un peu
incongru qui est tout à fait charmante
et finalement on s'aperçoit que voilà
même à certains ajouts on pourrait se
dire maintenant j'en ai rien à faire de
tout ça des conventions de l'art d'une
moralité oui mais les conventions on
pourrait dire ce à quoi on aurait apposé
théoriquement tout a été fait qu'est-ce
qu'on en a à faire de tout ce à quoi
j'ai ma vie et je suis ce que je veux et
bien finalement non
d'accord dans les clôtures tu te
retrouves dans l'écriture c'est assez
original parce qu'en fait les dialogues
sont comme incrustée dans le texte ne
s'est pas de point à la ligne jaune les
guillemets tout et tout et voilà mis
dans un seul texte entre guillemets
c'est le dernier ouvrage de l'auteur il
est il est mort en donnant quasiment son
manuscrit donc c'était l'année dernière
en deuil à 2 en 2014 et on sent une
une énergie et une volonté de vie qui
est très très forte comme s'ils se
sentaient le même pas un malade et que
voilà c'était comme si c'était quelqu'un
t'a dit vrai vite donc du coup le livre
on al'impression effectivement j'ai lu
en une soirée tellement c est quoi voilà
ni ses rentrées très beau très puissant
et un très beau nier sur la tendresse
voilà donc nos âmes la nuit de kent
haruf à lire absolument
[Musique]